welcome back a busy day on Capitol Hill
as Republicans in the House and Senate
worked to complete that tax reform
package the Senate bill released today
is at odds with the House version on a
number of key issues and with lots of
hard work ahead Congress's gone look at
there's an empty studio I thought I was
gonna have all these Congress there's no
one here that's right instead of
spending the necessary time to hammer
out this Agreement Congress men and
women are starting their weekend a
little bit early and for some
perspective just this year the Senate
has been out of session for 85 days it
doesn't mean their vacation days but
they're out of session and the House of
Representatives sat empty for only 67
days now compare that to the average
American who receives about eight
vacation days annually so they're out of
session eight days the regular people
joining us now our former congressman
and Fox News contributor jason Chaffetz
and representative Jim Renacci
of Ohio and a member of the House Ways
and Means Committee congressman Renacci
it's not fair of me really because when
you're not here I know you're still
doing work I get that I don't want to be
uncharitable or unfair however but I
will say let me just I will say this
with everything on the line I mean
everything in this tax reform package it
seems a little odd to me that that light
isn't on behind me in the Capitol dome
when you all aren't there doing a lot of
work is that does that strike you is a
little strange
well thank you for having me on Laura we
just finished today a package out of the
House Ways and Means Committee it's now
ready to move the House floor next week
members are getting the information
again we things don't just shut down
we've been talking as I've been
traveling back to Ohio with members so
members are getting a briefing they've
seen a lot of it already this week while
we did it and next week we'll get it
moved out of the house so we're going to
continue to do our work in the house
we're hoping the Senate continues to do
its work the goal was really get this
package done by the end of the year and
Jason again I'm not I want to be petty
here
but I do think
that it requires individuals to be in
town in the same room to hammer stuff
out yeah you can work at home I
understand that but there's a lot of
days where the session isn't happening
and we didn't do Obama care repeal we
flopped out at that and then everyone
left town and a lot of nominations have
gotten stalled
I think keep people in session suddenly
these Democrats are going to start
confirming these nominees now well
remember when mitch mcconnell's did be
on the microphone in the middle of July
and said hey we're gonna work deep into
August and get all these people
confirmed and then they went on recess
Paul Ryan with all due respect to the
speaker a couple weeks ago said hey
we're gonna work hard to stay through
Christmas he did that the day before
they went on an 11 day recess and the
problem is when you see the Ways and
Means Committee taking a huge important
vote to pass something out only to have
the Senate step on their toes this is
almost into the same hour saying hey
that bills going to be dead on arrival
and by the way we're going to introduce
a you know the the corporate reduction
in taxes we want to do that a couple
years from now I think talking to each
other
we've got wide receivers running into
each other to use a football analogy
that's the problem Congress and Renacci
that issue of delaying the corporate tax
rate cut for at least I guess a year
that's the Senate's idea of how to save
money that's a big chunk of the of the
money that would go right into juice in
the economy correct but they want to
delay that that's a big deal how do you
bridge that gap well absolutely and I
got to tell you as we were moving the
bill forward and and talking about it
even as of last night I was not going to
support it this morning if we were going
to delay it because I do believe we have
to do it as soon as we can we've got to
get the economy growing as quickly as we
can
we've got to get the tax cuts for middle
income taxpayers as quickly as we can
and that's why it's so important that we
do it on day one so I'm a big advocate
of that I'm glad to see that the
chairman held to that and that's one of
the reasons we do have the difference
between the House version of the Sen
version the chairman of ways and means
Kevin Brady was really good about making
sure he listened to the members as we
move this forward and that was a key
point we wanted to have it done January
1 we did not want to delay it and Jason
again we got seven tax brackets in the
Senate bill seven we got four in the
House bill they mock around a little bit
in the house with the mortgage interest
deduction they leave it at a million
dollars in the Senate bill I don't know
I'm not I'm not sure they're gonna get
get to a meeting of the minds here but
if they don't they can I think they can
kiss 2018 goodbye I think they don't get
something meaningful passed forget about
it I don't see why you how you can ask
the voters to vote for you again I'll
let you close it out Hey look I I was a
chairman and they told me hey we're
gonna work hard in the beginning of
January so on the day the president is
sworn in they can have health care and
about you know a st. Patrick's Day or so
we're gonna have tax reform you have the
Treasury Secretary's say we're gonna
have tax I don't have done by the time
ago in August and I just want to get it
done
just maybe that's what el Davis said
just hard all right guys